yeah welcome to new video it's a
15-minute game played here on chest cube
against them my friend Brandon here's
also got a channel on youtube so we both
will doing on comentarii on on this a
game i'll provide a link in the
description and maybe also do some
clickable thing here in the video so
that you can check in some comments also
alright i played the two nights tango or
Black Knights tango here quite a funny
opening which I actually played them
sometimes in tournament chess a couple
of years ago it's not that bad I mean
looks a bit bid weird maybe at first
sight but it has got some points young
Knight f3 so I'm like go see 6 cm and
depending on White's play now I just my
answers usually this transposes into
some sort of bogo Indian set up with
Bishop before check in case if you ask
yourself why we gotta draw already here
in our mini match via somehow had the
colors wrong so we agreed on an unrated
draw to switch colors last game we did
this duel comentarii thing i had wide so
we wanted to to switch colors yeah white
some main options here on Knight c3 g3
or a 3 a 3 sm maybe something like the
main line a 3 to prevent Bishop e-form
alright I go now Bishop before anyway
and this now really looks like Adams oh
well yeah some of the moves Knight f3
and knight c6 have been inserted y term
yeah now he usually plays Quincy 2 and
this term then it's a direct
transposition into um yeah Quincy two
nums onion
the Zurich variation or through behave
re-enter and German okay III this some
now can easily look like Rubinstein
would like having played the somewhat
weird-looking move knight c6 okay should
I castle first yeah i guess i can cancel
first and then decide on them on a pawn
structure black can play d 65 which is
so on a decent idea I can play md5 which
is also um yeah playable d5 with the
idea of taking on c4 that Bishop d6 back
and play you five so black wants to go e
five at some point here I wonder if I
played d630 castles of that he five is
good because of 95 maybe maybe I need to
take on c3 without them really yeah
white having spent the temple on a 3
i'll go d5 think i'm the surf is also
interesting alright so do i have
something better now than taking on c4
and playing Bishop t6 back good question
maybe I have from some waiting moves
that could be helpful quite often in
those kind of position black place moves
like age six and a 6 a-6 to secure the
bishops position on d6 which is about to
arise
but I need to be cautious a six and h6 a
lot the most powerful moves available
here I guess taking would be normal on
c4 and then dropping the bishop back on
a six time I think maybe maybe a three
years a move I don't really want to take
I want to get the bishop back to d6
which then this wouldn't make so much
sense tricky all right so I'll take him
and then this Bishop d 695 maneuver to
free my pieces I'm not sure if this is
really a normal a good line with
something similar at least them is some
is known maybe with the white having
played a three or something sort of
having wasted the temple all right so
what should why do now I mean if I saw
the most the most obvious move here
after before I need to play you five and
then white could play d 5 which would
lead to a yeah the standard card of
position which can often arise in and
somewhat irregular Queens gambit lines
for instance that she Goren the sum is
not much far away from being a chi Goren
with a knight on c6 cm
yeah I really need to go 45 otherwise
this Bishop bouncy eight it's just
useless piece as usual in any Queens
gambit type structure on of almost all
Queen side openings where black doesn't
fianchetto the bishop on g7 g8 Bishop
ism and the problem peace you need to
really get it to be 6 and play see 5 or
somehow manage a five otherwise it's um
hard to really get a dis game yeah not
much choice iam ok this is played
quickly yeah I think I should go to e7
which is normal here yam blacks idea now
is to transfer this night to g6 then
play along the lines of a six pawn to a6
push should be 727 sort of yeah keeping
the Queen side together and then try to
maybe get some peace activity on the
kingside we lie to h5 to our for on a g6
to f4 maybe but the some okay how to
hard to play this move you can always
capture player 5 kind of stuff so black
wants to shove his pieces towards the
King side and tries to hold the Queen
side okay I guess he wants to maybe
prevent Bishop g4 kind of move okay
let's let's play this first I need to go
there anyway well sometimes it's an idea
to to play for c6 and yeah maybe I
should have considered this maybe not
see 6m in this concrete position but the
general idea but ok Nazi success some
it's a final setting side on f4 H form
yeah white in general would try to play
on the C file open up the queenside we
are stuff like a 3 B form or Bishop e3
we should be 32 m complete development
another a general idea can be 95 to to
to get the bishop button at the moment
that he falls just hang so we cannot go
9 p-5 and you really should speed up a
bit I mean I'm really lame but here you
have really am quite normal moves and
available so yeah this might in 10 to 9
p-5 so I'll take away the b5 square
okay so let's play the normal museum and
try to be big quick not wasting too much
time yeah in fact if black here manages
to ya realize all is some ideas then he
sometimes really gets a nice attack on
the King side you have lots of pieces
pointed in this general direction let's
let's imagine like something like nine
h5 queen of 69 h2 a form very often you
need to play h6 pawn to h6 because I'm
let's say night h5 Queen f6 those two
moves he plays Bishop g5 and queen is
trapped so h 6 s move that you are very
often neat in this position it also
might prepare stuff like night h7 to to
g5 could also be a sensible regrouping
here and he spends two too much time him
just need to play Nolan moves we should
be three Europe you one before the kind
of stuff you do in these positions
another idea might be Bishop f1 and then
g3 to show up the Kings side so that
I'll never get a piece on f4 yeah I like
Bishop f1 may be a good prophylactic
move then the bishop is not them do much
on c4 anyway but he could play before or
while any kind of Huth okay Queen here
not sure if this has a concrete concrete
idea ok I want to prepare this this
thing here of Queen f6 but I think I can
I can
this now first two yeah sort of threat
night f4 not sure that it's really doing
so much but looks active here now maybe
look a really Bishop f1 now Bishop f1
not a chair for King h2 this kind of
stuff to prepare on g3 could be one of
my possible moves that I that I would
consider
I'm not so sure about this Quincy to
move I'm not convinced that this really
am improves White's position the queen
is may be useful on d1 closer to the
kingside to the Kings side it's not
doing much attacking wise yeah now we're
thinking about this move
so Quincy 8 is Quincy a to move the idea
being to play 9 f four then h6 gaining
this Bishop on Quincy Eddie cannot play
move like g4 I can just take it and then
neither form now maybe I can sometimes
even take on age three all right so
let's do this I hope it's a scatter
about the these kind of things on edge
to edge three I would really play Bishop
see a bishop f1 now adjust a good
prophylactic move or B should be three
to make sure that this Bishop is not not
exchanged white really doesn't want to
to allow on the exchange of this bishop
this is a g5 bishop the dark squares
then could be a real problem especially
this is a foursquare ok so now i can
play Knight to f4 right and then try to
to win this Bishop with I mean not
winning and sense of having extra piece
but getting the bishop with h6 I like
this position but it's a nice night
there on f4 that it took it and
fortunately in this concrete position I
cannot take with the porn i would like
to to free the five square but you can
play five this book on you won support
c5 so I need to take out the night but
that's not too bad I mean this is really
an annoying pc on on f6 alright so he
tries to may be prepared g3
alright so let's let's also check them
the the crude loose like f5 but this
looks more weakening than anything else
and maybe it is playable it takes bishop
at 594 might be able to take some well
g2gi three but let's check on this eerie
threatening G 303 I can take this pawn
you can play 90 and gently g3 it's a bit
the time consuming all this ok but well
i cain't again the bishop p.m. I don't
need to really am play for meteor it's
not not necessary anymore I could just
play Queen dat seven something and then
try to to to use the bishop pair and the
long run
yeah maybe I should should really
consider this but if I play Queen eatum
voluntarily he might really just play
play g3 and kick the night away I want
them to play nigeria this ok play a sort
of waiting move here which is maybe it's
still necessary I mean necessary is the
wrong word useful I meant ok this was
this idea i wanted to i want to exchange
it this way so if i now in retreat to g6
you might plane I g3 ok but I could play
night to h5 I could take also possible
just take on you two
so when I it's not a private game
someone cubits in here 9 takes d5 night
XD 5 I need to learn to silencer how is
this possible
how can I ignore spectators yeah I'm not
finding this this bloody button it's
called private why someone keep it sing
no idea i can eat you like a move here
first sorry about this we we really
wanted a private game and not having
some people cubed sing on this year and
irritate us I can pull up the ads page
but how do i set this this is weird okay
so let's continue to regroup here
getting the Queen er officer the
stranger the strange square is it here
no I don't know I know how to silence
the kibbutz's usually you have some sort
of thing to depress here but it is
private why is someone cute sing weird
alright so I replace the aria position
of the Queenie are only seven it didn't
do much good on on c8 anymore so this
whole operation num has netted me the
two bishops but how to continue one
general idea might be to play C 6 cm to
to open the position up it takes we
should take so something like this yeah
okay let's play c6 and open up the
position
usually a van ignore spectators button
but yet either isn't anyone really weird
okay so see 6m tries to open up the
position black it suddenly okay here but
it's um not a huge problem for white
this position I just see I could have
considered some five also wouldn't be so
bad out so of course it can take up a
solvent and c5 so the position has
opened up a bit so we traded see porn
was deep on with that in general should
should be a favorable trade for me yeah
this d6 Bishop is not great so it should
be on a 7 mm well see five a seven would
be a good good possible regrouping here
yeah and wider should try to to yeah
some our untangle his pieces and get the
the Bishop to c4 which is a good idea I
think he wants to play this so um hmm it
should be 8 and b 82 a7 vs. an idea we
should be a tourism hmm yeah white is
still okay here Bishop see 45 or so it's
a good way to to improve the pieces
you play something like wind c5 now at
least them then I can like in the drop
back okay I good move the bishop clearly
belongs on this diagonal so it should be
a sixth sense of threat now I don't
think so can take on f2 and then a six
and he's lost the f porn which I don't
think he wants yeah why does so okay
here just playing the normal kind of
strengthening moves so on Bishop a6 I
just take f2 and then take on a six with
the rook and he's got a weekend inside
it's okay he can play it it's not it's
not terrible
yeah the the somewhat bad thing here
about this position for black as I
always need to cover this the c5 pawn
and this is some bit uncomfortable here
I cannot play f6 at any point so when
how to improve this position
yeah Bishop t5s also yeah somewhat cubed
sing again now this is just just just
stupid hmm how do i improve this really
really not easy he's got Bishop t5 also
coming up okay I could take a play you
form
hm
yeah I want to try to trade the rooks
here rooks eh maybe I only took need to
move at some point iam yeah Bishop a
sick so I wasn't so great I don't think
don't think it was what this guy is keep
it sing here and really really wonder
why is able to okay so we're down to
close to two minutes now and we need to
speed up here
y'all need to take him okay yeah this
kind of exchange isn't so great for me
really
yeah I must be am conscious hear that
I'm not getting a worse position okay
should I try to exchange the rookie i
guess i should you may be here
yeah quindi three something like this
okay let's take it down now this Bishop
protect the porn yeah here white is just
slightly better I am really didn't get
much out of this here I offers me a draw
I don't think so still want to play you
need to UM I mean it's it's a friendly
game at all but you need to have a look
at the time once in a while I mean I'm
playing slowly but this is really taking
it a bit too far okay night to to see
form
so b5 don't want to play this be five a
day five okay
yeah you can play 95 now
somewhat we had this move not sure what
it what it is doing really I try to get
to see one here k attacking the knight
now yeah all right the time one here
just just slow alright so make sure to
check out so I'm his version of the game
I'll provide the link and yeah talk to
you soon in a new video